that's that's magnified when you have
children because they they have no say
well that's the other vulnerability I
have they put their kids out there okay
I don't know I'm not saying it's the
worst thing to do but it's not the
child's choice and they're very young
and you're making a ditch you look like
whoever did what they did to Michael
Jackson right yeah one of the things
that they did is they made him famous
way before he had any idea what the [ __ ]
that meant and they profited off of it
yeah they kind of pimped him out right
and that's kind of what's happened and I
destroyed him yeah ultimately the whole
thing destroyed them right and I just I
don't want to be a part of that I just
there's no that's smart I don't think
it's intelligent and I also don't this
is my real honest feelings I do not
think that Fame is I don't think that
people should aspire to it I think it
should be something that happens if
people like your work and then it's cool
it's fine but I think there's way too
much emphasis put on just trying to get
attention and it's being rewarded and
supported in this weird way there's
nothing wrong with getting attention but
it should make sense it should make
sense there should be some reason and if
it's out of balance yeah you know you
should you should probably look at like
why why is it out of balance like yeah
and lots of things that attract
attention are not things that we need
wait we want more of it's you know like
conflict
yes conflict that's a big one but it's
also the I'd like just Fame itself one
of the weirdest parts about it is that
you have to constantly be checking
yourself like all these people are nice
to you all these people or saying nice
things to you or being mean to you you
know one of the all people that you
don't even know so you can't rely on
them for your self esteem and you
certainly can't rely on them for
criticism you can't rely on them people
you don't even know that don't care
about you you know see you you're in
this weird position you have to be very
careful with who you communicate with
because one of the weirdest things
you'll see from famous people is all the
sudden they get this very straight
thing where they feel like people are
supposed to do things for them and you
know they don't they're not supposed to
pay for things and everything's supposed
to be easy and they're supposed to get
that that's so that's a weird one like
they they don't respond to criticism
well they don't understand that they're
still a human being in the middle of
growth know they're a [ __ ] star I'm a
[ __ ] star and I want this and I want
it now yeah and they're just like what
kind of [ __ ] [ __ ] is this
Do You Know Who I am yeah exactly we've
seen we've all seen like a version of
that right and they brought it the
problem though is that they know that
their [ __ ] stinks yes they know that
they're human they know so they're so
then they develop this sort of fraud
phobia right that people are gonna find
out what they really are
I mean I've seen this with fashion
models you know I used to hang out with
a lot of fashion models in Barcelona
that you know that whole story where I
lived in the mansion with the fashion
models did you talk about that could be
I don't know I'm not sure what the [ __ ]
we've talked about it's possible yeah
it's impossible yeah anyway so yeah a
fashion model come fame wealth we were
extremely wealthy and and that gets back
to the 70 grand a year thing and the
whole sort of question of you know
saturation you know what else it is it
it becomes a real problem with things
being too easy and life being like way
too patterned like you you everything is
very predictable in terms of like your
success you have plenty of money you
have adulation from fans without any
stress or duress you gonna have a little
bit of stress in terms of like trying to
manage your career but it's nothing like
trying to make it yeah I don't know if
I'm ever gonna make it stress that's a
totally different kind of stress I don't
know if I'm ever gonna be a success
dress that's real [ __ ] that goes away
once you definitely become Kanye West
whoever the [ __ ] you are and then you're
subject to your own demons cuz then
you're alone you're really alone you
can't even go to the grocery store you
spent any time with Jim Carrey no I
don't know I'd love to meet that guy yes
he seems like he's in a weird stage of
his life he seems to me like someone who
who you talked about you know you get to
us that that
pinnacle I mean you have to deal with
your demons yeah it seems like he's
dealt with them here now he's come out
the other side yeah and he's in this
very sort of this place of wisdom and
and yeah it I just think he he signed
Russell Brand is another guy who I think
I really admire where they are in their
lives and how they got there they sort
of went through the fire and they've
come out the other side somehow Russell
certainly has I know Russell he's a
sweetie he really is a super sweet guy
like Jim and - and really trying to like
be a better person yeah and a better
human and you know I don't agree with
him on everything he gets a little
social justice warrior II on some things
but I think it's just because he wants
to do good and he's like leaning towards
good he's leaning towards love and he's
like it's it's all for the right reasons
like